I was running through the six with my
woes you know what that means the six is
an area in Tehran seven woes
I'm James Davis and this is swag Soros
woes means your crew your walls are your
squad when you first hear Drake claiming
he was with his woes it's easy to assume
some sadder what was going on maybe he's
just being emo Drake again maybe Wallace
is just a personification of the
rapper's emotions but really the word
stands for working on excellence it
represents a brand of friendship woes
aren't merely acquaintances you always
aren't just any group of buddies your
woes are stand-up individuals who are
plotting to accomplish goals and win as
a team just because you're in a class
with someone or you're friends with him
on Facebook doesn't make them alone to
be someone's whoa y'all have to be tight
have a history for a significant bar
Matt Damon and Ben Affleck they woes
hell Ben & Jerry's ice cream guys they
gotta be Wallis too cuz the ice cream is
only judd apatow Seth Rogen Jonah Hill
James Franco they're each other's roles
and all they do is make funny movies
with their votes and you know how that
goes I'm starting to feel like
everyone who checks out swagger soars
with me is my whoa we hang out we talk
about women we stare at my jacket it's
amazing it's friendship it's worship I
couldn't do this without you I can't
wait to highlight all my walls next week
with a brand new work and remember
you're my whoa